well we have an audience full of people
who have been inspired by Olivia to take
some gutsy chances but before we hear
them um I feel like we should share ours
I'll share I was kind of sharing a
little bit of mine in the break but I I
get tattoos um well not all of them but
a lot of them are when not great things
happen um and I do it because I like the
reminder that I made it and like and and
it's some sometimes things seem so big
in your world at that moment and you
feel like you're not going to make it
and then you do and so usually that's
when I get the tattoo um one of my
favorites is on my middle
finger um yeah and it says DC and it's
because somebody made me feel and I
don't know I hope you never experienced
this or haven't but because I do think
we've progressed a little in this
industry but um yeah people can be very
mean I mean they can be just vicious and
it's you know if you're not successful
how they want you to be doing what you
want and it's usually their shortcomings
sure and I mean just someone was so
vicious and I was so tired of sitting in
a room where men just made me feel like
and then I was like you know what nope I
actually had the guts to finally say and
I was in my 20s you know and I started
at 19 so I was it took a minute but I
finally said like you know what I was
like actually I think this is about you
and I think this is about and I just
totally said everything I've ever wanted
to say in that moment so that's one of
my favorite t w that's beautiful yeah I
hope you don't go through that what's
one of yours oh my gosh my gutsy story
after that beautiful mine's going to
sound so silly I know no it won't make
it lighter okay okay I was a little
heavy for daytime yeah yeah daytime you
know I was thinking coming up here um
because we're at 30 Rock we're in New
York yeah what the second time I ever
performed in my career was on SNL and I
was 18 years
old I was so which is incredible I mean
what an honor but I was terrified yes
and it's so late it's so late yes for a
vocalist and it's so live uhhuh um for
the name and um I just remember being
terrified and being in my dressing room
and being like I don't know if I deserve
to be here this is terrifying but did it
anyway and I that that was Brave of me
but not not quite as beautiful as don't
do that that is very brave I'm done ASL
it's a little ner yeah
[Music]
[Applause]
yeah
thank you guys y'all have a great night
I'm going
home